Dame Joanna Lumley a very good morning
to you Dame Joanna thanks so much for
talking to us first of all tell us how
you got involved with Holocaust Memorial
Day Trust
I was simply invited and is it something
that I've always been supportive of this
memories of the Holocaust I've had the
great privilege to talk in Berlin to a
Survivor from a holocaust survival we
spoke so movingly and she said we have
to bear Testament to what happened we
have to remember this but of course all
the survivors are getting very very old
now and it seems that we must be the
ones to pick up the flag as it were and
to carry it on and say never forget what
happened never forget how what starts
with bullying and then becomes
discrimination then persecution and then
annihilation of entire races of people
just for what they are it's simply
unbearable and we've got to look out for
it whenever it rears it's in so I'm so
proud to be here today and we've been
handing out these little candles which
are say light the darkness it's to show
to shine a light onto the memories of
those who perished and to show our
solidarity for those who are suffering
persecution anywhere in the world for
any reason at all
terribly terribly important and it
mustn't be forgotten I can't emphasize
this more strongly it doesn't matter if
you're Jewish or not it doesn't matter
if you're gay or not or if you're black
or not all these different things if
you're Muslim or or any kind of religion
that is being persecuted for goodness
sake look out for the bullying and
remember that the Holocaust happened and
it was on the most falling things in
history unless we remember it and keep
it alive it will happen again
and how do you keep that memory alive
not only the horrors also the sacrifice
when it's nearly 80 years on from the
end of World War II
well the thing is is that it is going on
we have a representative here today from
Rwanda and all of us can remember that
appalling Massacre which is one kind of
person set against another kind of
person they were all neighbors they were
all the same people but one tribe as it
were slaughtering another we've got room
that human beings are tribal and we tend
to hate anything that isn't our own
tribe and so we've just got to be so
careful that we don't drift into the
same kind of uh
discriminatory stance is about people
who aren't like us remember in the
Holocaust people were murdered just for
who they were that's all just for who
they were so we've got to keep it alive
and remember that it's
it's latent in mankind and we've got to
crush it whenever it raises its head
okay would you want to lonely sadly that
don't have very long with you but thank
you very much for that very important
message we really appreciate your time
thanks so much thank you